If we have some mass, m,
and it is moving with some velocity,
let's say the magnitude of
that velocity we say is v,
we know that this object
right over here has momentum.
Translational momentum.
And that momentum, and we
use the Greek letter rho
to represent momentum.
Translational momentum
is defined as being equal
to the mass times the velocity.
This is all a review, we have other videos
where we talk about
translationial momentum,
and one way to think about it is,
"Well how hard is it to stop this thing?"
Literally in everyday language you think,
"Well how much momentum
does something have?
"The more momentum this has
the harder it's going to,
"the harder it is to stop it in some way."
And so we know if we wanna get
a little bit more mathematical,
that if we wanna change momentum,
we have to apply force
for some amount of time.
And so the magnitude of our force
times the duration of the
time that we apply it for,
force times time and
this is called impulse.
And this is once again, all review.
This is equal to change in momentum.
Let me do this in that yellow color.
That is equal to change in momentum.
So if you don't have any impulse,
especially if you don't have any net force
acting on an object,
its momentum is going to be constant.
You have a conservation of momentum.
And we use that idea in all sorts of
interesting physics
applications in the world,
and especially a lot of
cases using billiard balls
and whatever else.
So now let's try to take a similar idea,
but go into the rotational world.
So let's imagine you have a mass,
for the sake of this we're
gonna assume it's a point mass.
So you have a mass there.
And let's just say it's attached by,
essentially a massless wire,
to you know, it's just nailed down
right over here.
And so this right over here would be
its center of rotation,
and so you could imagine
if someone applied
a torque to this mass,
this mass could start
rotating in a circle.
And you can just assume that maybe
it's sitting on a, you know the screen,
this is kind of a frictionless surface,
there's no air resistance.
And so then it will, if
you apply a torque here,
it will start rotating.
And so you could think about,
"Well there might be an idea,
"just as momentum is this idea of,
"well how hard is it to stop something?"
You might say, "Well how?"
And this is, stop translating
something from moving.
You might think, "Well
maybe there's a similar idea
"of how hard is it for something,
"or how hard is it to
stop rotating something?"
And you could imagine that
that idea has been defined
and it has been defined
as angular momentum.
So let me make this clear,
this right over here is momentum.
And over here we'll talk
about angular momentum.
And actually both momentum
and angular momentum
are vector quantities.
So here I just wrote
kind of the magnitudes
of velocity and momentum.
But momentum is a vector
and it could be defined,
the momentum vector could be
defined as equal to the mass
which is a scalar quantity
times the velocty.
Times the velocity vector.
Now the same thing is
true for angular momentum,
but I'm gonna stay focused on
the magnitude of angular momentum.
Angular momentum can have
direction as you can imagine
you could rotate in two different ways,
but that gets a little
bit more complicated
when you start thinking about
taking the products of vectors
because as you may already know
or you may see in the future,
there's different ways of
taking products of vectors.
But just to get the intuition
of angular momentum,
I'll focus on the magnitudes.
So angular momentum is defined
and the letter used is L.
I did a lot of research
to try to figure out
why it is called L, and I
could not find a good reason.
So in the message board below
if anyone has a good reason
I would like to know
why angular momentum is called L.
A lot of the best arguments I saw
is that almost everything else was,
all the other letters were used up
for other ideas in physics.
But anyway, angular momentum is defined,
and it's defined very similarly.
Just as kind of torque
is the thing that can
change how something rotates,
and force is the way
that something changes
how something translates it,
and torque is force times distance
from the center of rotation,
everything in kind of the rotational world
is defined in a similar way.
You kind of take the analogue
in the translational world,
and you multiply it times the distance
from your center of rotation.
So angular momentum is defined as
mass times velocity
times distance from the center of rotation
so let's call this distance
right over here, r.
r for radius 'cause you could imagine
if this was traveling in a circle
that would be the radius of the circle.
m, v, r.
Actually let me be a little
bit more careful here.
It's the magnitude of the velocity
that is perpendicular to the radius.
Sometimes it might be called
the tangential velocity.
So this symbol right over here,
this is the magnitude of the velocity
that is perpendicular to the radius.
So it would be that
magnitude right over here.
This is what we define
as angular momentum.
Now what I will tell you here is,
just as in the absence of a net force,
momentum is constant.
We know, and I haven't
shown it to you yet,
I haven't proven it to
you yet mathematically,
but in the absence of torque,
so if torque is equal to zero,
we'll do torque in pink.
If torque is equal to zero,
if there's no net torque going on here,
if the magnitude of
torque is equal to zero,
then we will have no change.
No change in angular momentum.
And we will look at that
mathematically in a few seconds.
But just from this
there's a very interesting
thing that arises.
And something that you might have observed
at even the Olympics or in other things.
And this is the idea that you can,
by changing your radius,
you could actually change
your tangential velocity.
And as we've seen in previous videos,
tangential velocity is closely related to
angular velocity.
So let's explore that a little bit.
So when we write it in the world where,
well actually you see
it straight out of this,
if L is constant, if r went down,
so let me write this down.
So let me rewrite it over here.
So L, whoops.
L is equal to mass times
tangential velocity,
or actually well yeah,
or the velocity that's
perpendicular to the radius,
times the radius.
Now what happens,
if we assume that this is constant,
if we assume that there's no torque,
so we're in this world.
So this over here is going to be constant.
So what happens if we were to reduce r?
Somehow this wire started
to reel in a little bit
or started to wrap around here,
and that's actually a reasonable thing,
you could imagine as it rotates
it starts to wrap around
this thing so the wire gets shorter.
So if r goes down,
and this is constant, the
mass isn't going to change,
Well if L is constant,
mass isn't changing,
r is going down, tangential velocity,
or the velocity that's
perpendicular to the radius
is going to go up.
And if we wanna think about it,
we can think about it in
terms of angular velocity,
we know that angular velocity,
which we would measure
in radians per second,
we would use the symbol omega,
omega is defined,
and we go into much more
depth in this in other videos,
as tangential velocity,
the magnitude of the velocity that is
perpendicular to the radius,
divided by the radius.
Or if you solve for tangential velocity,
you get v is equal to
is equal to omega r.
And so if you substitute back into this,
really this definition
for angular momentum,
you get angular momentum
is equal to mass times this times r.
So mass times, I'm just
substituting for velocity here,
times omega r,
times r.
Which of course is just omega r squared.
So once again we do the same exercise.
If our radius goes down,
what happens to our angular velocity?
Remember we could measure this in
angles per second or radians per second,
well if this is constant,
remember we're assuming
that there's no net torque
being applied to the system,
so we're still in this
world right over here.
If we assume that this
thing isn't changing,
but the radius were to change,
what's going to happen to omega?
Well omega is going to go,
omega is going to go up.
Now likewise, if the radius got longer,
So the radius got longer,
what's going to happen to omega?
Omega is going to go,
omega is going to go down.
So if you reduce the radius
you're going to start spinning faster
if you increase that radius,
you're gonna start spinning slower.
And you have seen this,
or I think there's a high likelihood
that you have seen this
probably at the Olympics when
you have seen figure skaters.
Where they might start spinning
and they have their arms out.
So when their arms are out
you could say that their
radius is further out.
And obviously a figure skater is
a much more complex
system than a point mass.
You could imagine a figure skater is
a bunch of point masses.
Well you could just model a figure skater
as a huge number of point masses
at different radii,
and you would wanna sum
up their angular momentum,
but the essence of what is happening is
is when her arm is out
the average radius when you're calculating
all of the point masses in
her arms and all the rest,
the average radius is higher.
And then when she pulls them in,
when she pulls them in
that radius goes down,
and her angular velocity goes up.
And you see that. They start spinning,
and then without applying any torque,
when they pull their arms in
they start spinning faster.
And then if they push their arms out,
once again without applying any torque,
they start spinning slower.